[Music]
good morning hello we were just waiting
for some people to come over from the
overflow simulcast but I think we'll go
ahead and begin good morning again my
name is Jane Farber I'm the director of
the list Visual Arts Center here at MIT
and it's my very great pleasure to
welcome you to the listeners annual max
Wasserman forum on contemporary art as
you know this year's topic is the
university as patron of cutting-edge
architecture just a few words about the
forum the annual Max Westerman forum on
Contemporary Art was established in
memory of max Wasserman who was an MIT
class of 1935 and who was a founding
member of the MIT Council for the Arts
this public forum addresses critical
issues in contemporary art and culture
through the participation of renowned
scholars artists and arts professionals
we are extremely grateful to Jeanne
Wasserman for her continued generous
support of this project and for being
such a superb member of our advisory
council thank you so much Jean for
everything
and thank you to Peter Wasserman - for
all of your help with this year's for
him and also to the members of the
Wasserman farm committee jenni Fucci be
learning andrea miller Keller Jerry
Friedman Dorothy annoy Levine
Marjorie Jacobson and special thanks
also to Alan Brody associate provost for
the arts here at MIT I think I just
changed somebody's sorry also I would
like to especially thank William J
Mitchell who is the academic head of
media arts and sciences here at MIT for
his generous collaboration with us on
this project it wouldn't have been
possible without him
and I must give my very very sincere
thanks to the list center staff they've
just done an amazing job on this project
and I'd like to recognize especially
David frylock be learning hiroko Kikuchi
barber pine and Camilo álvarez as well
as the many volunteers all these nice
people in yellow t-shirts who have given
their time to help this happen this
morning before I introduce our forum
participants I'd like to make just a few
brief more announcements there will not
be a reception following this event but
at 4 p.m. today at Simmons hall on
Vassar Street there we the dedication of
a new work by Dan Graham in Simmons Hall
and we would like to invite you all to
be present for the dedication of his
ying-yang pavilion so a campus map is
included in your package website it
looks like this and Simmons is marked
there with a red number two so you can
find it and we hope you'll use this map
in the interim to guide you around
campus if you'd like to see some of the
other public art and projects on campus
and also on the back there is a list of
restaurants if you would like to have
lunch in the area so we hope you'll find
that helpful and I'm sure many of you
want to take a tour of Frank Gehry Stata
Center and you can do this at an open
house on May 24th please go to the web
at MIT edu slash evolving slash for more
information on that and tours of Steven
halls Simmons Hall can be arranged
through Simmons Hall so
you need to email a request for a tour
to sim tours request at MIT edu the
people and the yellow t-shirts can give
you this information if you if you
missed it and also we hope you'll have a
chance to visit the list Center at 20
Ames Street as there are two remarkable
exhibitions currently on there my age is
a Patricia urgent architecture and the
first u.s. solo show of Warsaw based
artists are surgeon risky and on view
and our media test wall is a me Glow
buses video electric sheep this lecture
is being recorded for archival purposes
and will be webcast on the MIT world
website so if you missed something today
you can revisit the form at the website
in the future
we apologize to the many and we're not
able to accommodate in this auditorium
and hello to those of you watching the
simulcast in 10 to 50 we appreciate your
patience and your understanding and
finally we're very lucky that the
remarkable individuals are we're here
today were able to take time out of
their very busy schedules to be with us
so they will need to leave the
auditorium immediately after the forum
so we regret that they won't be able to
stay around and converse with you we
hope you'll understand
finally I truly regret to inform you
that there's a change in today's forum
Steven Hall has back trouble and will
not be able to join us we're very very
disappointed he had hoped he would be
able to come but after an MRI and the
doctors advice he wasn't able to join us
so we wish him well and hope he's well
soon and we're very sorry that he can't
be here today but we have wonderful
participants today our participants are
architects Frank Gehry and Robert
venturi architectural historians and
theoreticians James Ackerman Kimberly
Alexander and kiyong Park MIT president
Charles vest executive president John
curry and William Mitchell who is head
of the program in media and Arts and
Sciences at MIT he will be serving as
moderator if I can just give you some
brief biographical information about our
panelists then we can begin James
Ackerman is an architectural historian
in the 2001 winner of the prestigious
bolzen Prize for history of architecture
his work Palladio has had immense
influence to it to its innovative way of
examining pay
and the role of the Works Commissioner
in creating cultural significance for
architecture
James Ackerman's talk will provide
context for the forums discussion of
current university buildings within a
historical perspective Kimberly
Alexander is an architectural historian
who blends social history perspective in
her work with the built environment she
was the first curator of architecture
and design at MIT a post that she held
for ten years during which she organized
significant and exhibitions on MIT is
great buildings such as Alvaro Altos
Baker house and William Wells Bosporus
1916 master MIT campus plan she will
discuss mi t--'s particular role as a
patron of architecture Frank Gehry as
I'm sure you all know is the designer of
mi t--'s new ray and Marie Stata Center
as well as the Walt Disney Concert Hall
in Los Angeles the Guggenheim Museum
Bilbao and many many others his
buildings have received over 100
national and regional AIA awards
including the Pritzker architecture
prize in 1989 the premiere accolade of
the field and many more to numerous to
mention William J Mitchell is academic
head of Media Arts and Sciences and
professor of architecture and media arts
and he was the former dean of
architecture at MIT he also serves as
architectural aid advisor to the
president of MIT his recent publications
including me puss-puss the side Berg
self in the network city he topia human
urban life Jim but not as we know it and
city of its space place in the info bond
Robert venturi is Extension Commission's
as well as his teaching advising writing
and lecturers have received national and
international attention
his major campus buildings include five
at Princeton University three at
Dartmouth and five at the University of
Pennsylvania Robert venturi snoo murus
words include the Republic of Italy's
commendatory of the order of merit he's
gotten the presidential National Medal
for the Arts and he also was a recipient
of the prestigious Pritzker architecture
prize Charles vest has been president of
MIT since 1990 he holds degrees from
West Virginia University the University
of Michigan he chairs the u.s.
department energy Task Force on the
future of science programs and he's a
vice chair of the Council on competitive
in the past year of the Association of
American Universities and he's now
serving as a member of the commission of
the intelligence capabilities United
States regarding weapons of mass
destruction
he's also leaving us so we are truly sad
about it because he's been a fabulous
fabulous president respondents for today
RMIT executive vice president John
Currie an artist curator at knack
textual theoretician kiln Park John
curry MIT executive vice president was
formerly vice president for business and
finance and chief financial officer at
the California Institute of Technology
it was also administrative
vice-chancellor and chief financial
officer of the University of California
in Los Angeles he's authored numerous
articles on academic finances and
management he's a trustee of the
National Association of colleges and
university business officers and a
trustee and chair of the Finance
Committee of the College Board kiyong
Park is my friend and the founder
director of the International Center for
urban ecology in Detroit and New York
City and he was the founding director of
the storefront for art and architecture
in New York he was also commissioner for
the International section of the Kwangju
Biennale in Korea in 1997 he organized a
wonderful architectural show called
images of the future the architecture of
a new geography finally there will be a
15-minute presentation from our
intermission excuse me following present
best presentation so without further ado
if you would join me in welcoming James
Ackerman who will make our first
presentation
may I remove the PowerPoint could I get
the PowerPoint out of the way because I
have to put my notes down
I'd like somebody else to do it good
morning honored to be initiating this
very promising colloquium and I want to
add to the expressions of thanks that
were delivered by the directors of the
center my own warm feelings of gratitude
towards Jeanne Wasserman who's been a
colleague of mine over the years my talk
is divided into two parts the first part
has to do with the organization of
university environments in the second
addresses the growth of the phenomenon
of what might be called the signature
building which is the primary subject of
the discussion today
[Music]
here we see together an incense of early
campus organization did the late 17th
and early 18th century we have William
and Mary on the left and Harvard on the
right let me emphasize that these were
colleges with very limited aims at the
beginning it was characteristic it early
building of the kind to joy together
residence with classrooms and other
functions of the college and both of
these cases the project was conceived in
a new form which was by no means
generally characteristic for example at
Dartmouth College in this print around
1850 all the buildings was strung out in
the line in rise above the common of
hannover and the same thing was true
Yale University Yale College at the time
which was on New Haven common ground and
just stretched out in a line worked out
by Trumbull who was a university advisor
of the time it was not very much later
that is at the beginning of the 19th
century that conceptions of the college
as a organized organism began to take
place on the right you have Union
College which was designed by the French
American architect rah made in 1813 ad
conceived as you see it here with a
central focal building and others around
it now the focal build
of these days I think was different from
the kind that we're going to be talking
about today
it was a urbanistic event in fact we won
of Jefferson's Virginia on the left it
was very much like Romney's conception
it was a round building with a portico
in front a kind of pantheon recollection
the remain scheme is interesting in that
this very rigid French type of
organization was surrounded by a
picturesque English garden so there was
always a kind of eclecticism in the
conception of the American campus I
don't know whether the choice of Rama
was due to a desire to suggest the kind
of greco-roman background the ideology
of campus planning we really developed
later Jefferson had a very clear idea of
what a university should be he put the
different disciplines at different
pavilions as you could see on the right
the library is building on the far left
ad these pavilions that are joined by
porticos the pavilions on either side
were places where the discipline was
each discipline had a professor who
lived upstairs in the building and the
students were downstairs this was partly
to distinguish the intellectual
environment in this way and partly for
crowd control the professor was supposed
to be able to take care of the students
who were living at the porticoes
underneath and keep them from rioting
which was
very characteristic thing for students
to do at the time now can't see my note
anyway I think I know what I'm gonna say
so each of these pavilions had a
different architectural style and it was
it was Jefferson's idea that the style
of the building would teach
architectural students about the history
of architecture it was rather a ditsy
idea the one of them is taken out of
Pilate owes for books of architecture so
that's it was interesting to me now
after the classical start we have a plan
for the Michigan University of 1838
which you see on the right by Alexander
Jackson Davis who did universities a lot
he was perhaps the first one architect
to be continuously hired by universities
and why you among them and could change
styles at will here is the gothic plan
for the university which envisioned the
single building at the start with a
whole environment that could be
developed later that was not accepted
and the actual michigan campus looked
the way it does on the right here
in 1850 which was the same thing as
dartmouth and yale just a string of
buildings now the next stage was in the
later 19th century and there's a big
change at that time for example you see
here on the left the college of new
jersey which
in 1896 became Princeton it followed the
idea of their most famous President
Woodrow Wilson that it'd be a place
quote to those who would learn and be
with their own thoughts and so it was
isolated from its environment with a
cloistered system on the right you see a
design in 1894 the University of Chicago
and here the Gothic dominates also this
is undoubtedly because of the thought
that the Gothic period was one of
contemplation and enrichment in the
model of the English University now
we're in the 1890s and at that time
these colleges increasingly developed
into universities that meant a great
deal of physical diversity the buildings
had to serve different purposes and at
the same time as some of the
establishments were being done in a very
highly organized way others began to
have to build buildings that didn't fit
the plan because they had new functions
Rockefeller was behind of funding for
the University of Chicago which you see
on the right in the late 19th century
the issue issue of styles became very
important because the style of the
architecture was intended to express a
particular attitude towards learning
for example Princeton was bitten by
Anglophilia at this point
and it was largely an Episcopalian
organization so that the attachment to
the British College environment of
cloisters was very strong
imitating Oxford and Cambridge the the
display is one of monkish learning and
closed from the community I didn't
intend to find such a unrevealing slide
as the one on the left but what I did I
thought that does show the relationship
of the university to the community now
at the same time Columbia in the mid
nineties had turned towards the
classical driven by on the one hand the
bows are background of leading
architecture at the time this was McKim
Mead and white on the other hand by new
attitudes toward learning this was the
start of the elective system and there
was an Enlightenment background rather
than the cloister as the model had the
same of course was true much later on at
MIT as I think you'll hear shortly and
finally the last stage in the planning
of the American campus I for reasons of
time I'm leaving Stanford University out
of the picture because it
it's eccentric with relation to the rest
but Illinois Institute of Technology
dates from 1939 and it's designed by
Mies van der Rohe and the ideology
modernism now supplants that of
historical association it was an attempt
to get away from this attachment to
particular historical background and he
planned his original plan was continued
in later construction and I want to note
that the organization of the building is
quite the buildings are quite different
from the style the style is absolutely
modernist the organization is quite
classical the central axis buildings
that go off from it as a kind of a
conception that's very hard to a dog to
in the casual way that occurred in other
places now the second part of what I
would to speak about is the the
individual building the beginning of
turning to architects for because of an
interest in their own mode of expression
I would say came with Seaver Hall at
Harvard in 1878 Harvard also has the
University Hall by Bulfinch but that was
a fitted building this is a fit-out
building these are increments which are
related to academic innovation this is
the first classroom all classroom
building of importance in the American
tradition so we're getting one building
at a time now and they're the new
buildings are either anonymous or
seeking to blend into the background or
their it stand out because of
architectural distinction and the
realization this goal required employing
architects and willing to give them
substantial leeway and develop
design now coming out to more recent
times I'm sure you all recall a number
of instances of what might be called
signature buildings in different
university settings on the Left what
they call the whale in Yale University a
hockey rink designed by Eero Saarinen on
the right the the richest laboratory at
the University of Pennsylvania of 1958
which you see here by Louie Kahn they
Saarinen building is I think 1953 that
the same is true of the building the
dormitory by Alto at MIT although that
does fit better than most of these and
the the carpenter center at Harvard
which fits less well than most of these
now finally there's a very interesting
phenomenon that when Illinois Tech had
to grow and a new architect of repute
came into the picture the original
conception was so strong there that even
a very far out architect like REM
koolhaas fit into it in part of his
conception and out of it in another part
but this building which I haven't seen
in the flesh
seems to be representative of the
tension that I've been
speaking about and so let's ask the
questions which I'm sure will be
discussed in the panel about what's
behind the signature building the first
of all fundraising is an important
element the the patron demanding
distinction rather than blending in and
there's commonly really since the
beginning of this century a abandonment
of a link between a philosophy of
education and its embodiment in a
historic style so the style that becomes
independent of the theory a signature
building is a feather in the cap of the
university striking buildings attract
attention and publicity and give a
desirable impact on potential applicants
to the University and seems to Express
up-to-date neurs modernity finally in
earlier times while a skilled purveyors
of gothic in classical styles that might
have been the same people were often the
most qualified for the job today the
most qualified bring with them bold
though often exceedingly costly and
sometimes unworkable individualized
proposals last of all architects
reputations are based on his or her
singularity the university purchases
purchases a distinctive style as much as
the skill and executive ability of the
this is seiner thank you
[Applause]
that's not the way I want to start
great thank you good morning everybody
I knew as soon as I saw the laptop go
off the podium it's gonna be a rough
start good morning thank you
architecture may be called the pros as
sculpture and painting are the poetry of
art its first principles are
truthfulness good sense perspicuity
considerations of method order form
clearness precision and sobriety are
what make a good working style both in
writing and in building so said William
Robert we're the founder of mi t--'s
department of architecture to William
Barton Rogers in 1865 as he stood on the
brink of inaugurating their new program
in the construct of place as artists and
scholars as diverse as Eudora Welty to
Simon Schama even to William ware have
observed exerts both the most mundane
and the most powerful influences on our
sense of experience of memory and of
myth the power of place and the ability
to create a sense of place through
identity is what gives the study of
architecture its driving force today I'd
like to offer some thoughts about the
particular opportunities that the
building of MIT provided both the
challenges and the things that fostered
a shared sense of place throughout
American culture at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology the architecture
that is defined mi t--'s campus through
a century and a half has been the
embodiment of the vision of its founders
of 1861 these builders of structures and
institutions were cognizant of the
educational design on which they
embarked and that it wasn't sell was
itself an experiment they were sensitive
to the ways in which their efforts would
be recognized and scrutinized in the
public sphere through war and peace
prosperity and depression achievement in
crisis conquest and calamity this
architecture has been designed to
represent a progressive innovative and
yet eminently practical vision of what
an institute could be the philosophy and
mission of MIT have been reflected in an
unparalleled melding of architecture and
and despite occasional lapses and
nuances this vision and its
representation whether it be in built
architecture and curriculum has been
remarkable for a constancy of thought mi
t--'s campus architecture is a
progressive an innovative body ment of
the goals principles and vision of the
Institute
although these goals and objectives have
changed involved over the years as they
continue to do today Wilton Barton
Rogers and the founders in 1861 were
extremely aware of this experiment at
hand and I show you here two views of
the Rogers building in Boston's Back Bay
the building in the foreground was the
building of the Natural History and on
the top screen and on the far portion of
the upper screen was the MIT building
the tech building the first physical
manifestation that at MIT an expression
of its informing principles may be seen
in this building this represented what
was considered the high style of the day
at mid nineteenth century with its
French academic character detail and
flourished oops significantly for its
contribution to the public sphere mi
t--'s founders were able to cite their
inaugural eveson edifice boldly within
the cusp of a much larger experiment
which was the shape of shaping of public
space which was the creation of Boston's
Back Bay aligned themselves with the
Society for Natural History the founders
had petitioned the Massachusetts
legislature for a grant of land a
request which the legislature eventually
conceded furthermore not only the active
physical act of filling the Back Bay was
an important achievement but also
following the grand scheme that Barrett
Loosli that Baron von Houseman had
evolved for Paris elegant public
buildings wide boulevards mandated
height and building setbacks signaled
Bostonians aspirations to be ranked
among the community of civilized nations
even the drawings for the Rogers
building were sent home from Paris where
the architect William Gibbons Preston
was studying at that time
transcending it's elegant appointment
the Rogers building was consonant with
the very practical needs of the
Institute and was highly functional
classrooms libraries laboratories
museums offices and so on in short it
was an ideal building in an ideal
location to carry out an ambitious
post-civil war educational goals in the
initial departments of chemistry physics
engineering mathematics and architecture
it's interesting in terms of the design
of the Rogers building that it was so
based on French prototypes that was
prophetic in terms of the teaching in
the department for many years in 1872
MIT brought in the first French
professor to teach architecture in the
person of Eugene Lata and this French
influence of the occult abodes art would
continue into the 1920s and 30s all the
way up through Jacques Carlo and to a
lesser extent Lawrence B Anderson I'm
showing you here Frenchman Desiree Debra
Dell who has one of the most interesting
monikers when you read it as an American
of constant desire Debra Dell quite an
interesting character who inspired his
students in in very new ways and his
building right across from what was the
technology building the Berkeley
building the role that the architecture
department also played in a shaping of
core values as one I will touch on today
for their times throughout the history
of the Institute when the faculty and
students in the department plays
significant roles in shaping the campus
and its ideology that Rogers envisioned
architecture is one of the original
departments is clear in his original
scope and plan he brought in the young
dedicated William Robert ware who I show
you here left in a toga at a party of
George post house in 1885 and one of his
buildings in the Back Bay the first
church where would go on to found the
Department of Architecture at Columbia
as well
well we're turned to the occulta Bozarth
for a well-honed time-honored system of
instruction he visited numerous
practitioners throughout Europe and
spent a particularly productive time in
England bringing back drawings of models
and photographs for the fledgling
architectural museum another first I
show you here images that we are
collected abroad from English
practitioners on the top and down below
one of the drafting rooms the idea here
was that the instruction was practical
but also visual and very very tactile
and by being surrounded by these objects
and artifacts that would become a way
for you to learn there was also a very
strong sense in where's pedagogy that it
was a way of elevating public taste and
public education many of the students
this was a land-grant College if you'll
recall he felt would never get to travel
to Europe so instead he tried to bring
the whole of Europe back to his students
so the Rogers building then was a
paradigm of progress and new vision it
was a school of technology and science
as opposed to a School of Agriculture
the location of the building also
signaled a new vision was the latest
design being sent from Paris there was a
numerous first associated with it it was
young it was progressive the faculty was
well trained and well educated there was
a focus on physical as well as mental
rigor and of course what we hear so many
times that MIT learned by doing by the
late 1880s and 1890s it was very clear
that this experiment had been a success
and MIT had long outgrown its original
campus buildings there wasn't a campus
there there was no more room for
expansion the back bay had become very
crowded and the Institute began looking
for a new home this time the Institute
chose an area that was not currently
under major development and moved to the
river side in Cambridge the the chance
for the new technology to fulfill the
vision of Rogers and the founders was
seen as inextricably inextricably
with this particular site I'm showing
you here a view again by Desiree Deborah
Dell the Frenchman because there were
certain things in qualities in this
initial design that carried through many
subsequent designs this was completed
about 1912 just before Diptera del died
but I'd like you to see obviously the
strong axial plan the Bozarth symmetry
but one interesting thing that follows
through with Debora Dell is the
connected aspect of the buildings and
that's something that we'll see
happening over and over and over again a
sub-theme
that could have been developed today
also in terms of patronage were the
various squabbles that continued
throughout the various buildings as late
as the 1920s and 30s we still have
architects who came up with designs and
engineers who felt that they hadn't had
there were not rewarded for their
efforts on behalf of the Institute and
the letters in the Institute archives
speak well to that so if you think of
Cambridge and the new technology is the
fulfillment of Rogers and others vigeous
built vision and now of course the
Institute is headed by Richard McLaren
you get a sense I'd like to take a
little shift here a sense of the public
palpable excitement over the new
building or the new buildings in 1920
I took a scan through about five
different tour guides and tourist
brochures that were completed and there
is such a palpable sense of pride and
excitement over the new technology and
you see it everywhere everyone was using
everyone's talking about it and as one
of the guides quite simply states the
tech is simply the best in its field
this is 60 years after founding which i
think is an impressive amount of press
the thing to accomplish in such a short
time not bad for a small modest
land-grant college at its start for its
next venture the Institute selected one
of its own William wells Bosworth
Bosworth was an alum he'd studied in in
Paris and I think that's another theme
that
carries the early years of the Institute
is that the the architects were either
faculty or former students and so the
incident had a pattern of going to its
own to help it further its vision so
there's this very strong intertwining of
the teaching system coming back and then
influencing the architecture now I think
at first glance you might feel that
there's a bit of a pedestrian quality to
the classicism of Bosworth's scheme but
there's ended up being a very very
influential design we've already seen
some elements of classicism this is
return to classicism I think in some
ways you can think of it as a return to
normalcy after the horrors of World War
one
something that MIT was thinking more and
more about and we continue to think more
about as we reached into World War two
period also it embraced a number of new
technologies some of my famous favorite
visions of this building or where you
have railroad and I should say of
Killian Court weave railroad cars Spurs
bringing in supplies right next to horse
and donkeys with carts so there's this
sort of changeover going in terms of
transition and technology ultimately on
massive building 7 had poured-in-place
concrete factory sash metal windows so
that you have again sort of a tension
between the the actual architecture and
the creation of that the great chord in
rotunda was dedicated in 1916 with
additions made through the 1930s when 77
massive finally opened in another side
the architecture department was actually
the last one to move to the massive
address remaining holed up in the old
Rogers building with their french bazaar
drawings and medieval sculpture
something which made the Institute
realise it was high time to get them
into Cambridge the first building to
break with the Bosworth axial plan again
we turn to to student and faculty member
Lawrence B Anderson working with Herbert
Beckwith in 1929 with a swimming pool
and I'm sure
two views for those of you who are
familiar with this swimming pool and you
see the the new status center behind the
pool you'll note you'll notice how much
the disposition of this building has in
fact has in fact changed but it was
quite again a very important moment for
MIT not only in terms of breaking with
the original master plan but also
because of what it said about the
importance of physical and athleticism
to the student body at this time there
were great many thoughts going on but
how do we keep not only the mind healthy
but the body healthy and the swimming
pool was one of those if the new
technology was fulfillment of vision the
post-world War two campus questioned
that vision tremendously I'm sure many
of you know this image as building 20
which was certainly eminently adaptable
to scores and scores of uses and and
dearly loved by by many many students
and professors what I'd like to do is
talk about the vision on the post World
War two vision as embodied by Baker
house and what that meant for the
Institute it represents a tremendous
shift in thinking at MIT following the
upheavals of World War two and it caused
MIT two to begin thinking about
offerings for its students there were a
number of things that happened including
the the Louis Committee the Lewis report
was issued in 1949 which had
far-reaching curricular recommendations
and among those recommendations was the
formation of a new School of Humanities
and social science I think that's
something that a lot of people aren't
aware of in terms of how long the the
connection with humanities existed at
this institution it was considerable
importance to MIT at this time as well
because MIT was still largely a commuter
school and the idea of having a
residential life component was seen as
very very important in terms of creating
a humanitarian vision for the students
one of the singular events leading up to
this was in 1949 mit hosted the
mid-century convocation and the
convocation actually began with Winston
Churchill's speech in the Boston Garden
and as his backdrop
was this view of Baker house Baker house
was the future and MIT was the future
they were inextricably linked bringing
Alvar Aalto to MIT for that we need to
thank William Worcester and I think
Worcester is someone who frequently does
not get the attention for the role that
he played here at MIT you can you can
get a sense of his excitement when
Worcester says Alto flew here so comes
fresh from the problems of
reconstruction of destroyed towns in
Finland I would say that possibly the
greatest contribution is adding richness
to the stream of teaching in the school
which gives zest to each problem for
each student
professor Alto is not to conduct a
studio for a few who rather to meet with
each group and each individual during
his term so here again we have a link
between teaching and building ideology
here I show you an interior view shortly
after completion Altos said about
Baker house in a letter to his wife I've
improved almost every part of the
building now it is really going to be
good it always happens that the real
inspiration comes and the exact forms
appear only after construction has
started as for the additional rooms well
it went exactly the way you thought it
was best keeping the basic form of the
building with some improvements but
increase in the number of rooms with a
stepped extension on one end turned out
best as always your instinct was right
now you can sense how excited he was but
of course the number of these expansions
were cut due to budget restraints so
after the the influential Louis report
the Institute moved forward into the
second century campaign and that
generated a series of other very
important buildings and I show you here
on the far screen the Kresge chapel and
Kresge Auditorium again by Sarah Ninh
and on the opposite screen the Student
Center by Eduardo Catalano with the
second century campaign the focus was
again on providing facilities for the
students and and again returning to
those to those earlier visions and goals
and founding principles about student
activities student life
and a well-rounded environment the
Wiesner building again shows MIT going
back to its students I show you here a
photograph of the weasoner building and
in the upper corner is actually a
student drawing thesis drawing by the
architect IM Pei ion Pei was a student
here in 1940 and completed some very
very interesting work at that time as a
student he was brought to MIT also in
the 1960s for the green building and
then made a return appearance here with
Wiesner this was a building again had a
very long gestation period based on
actually going back to that 1960-61
based on what were the needs of the
students at this time how do we bring
creative activities and and art into the
lives of our students so again you have
the Institute turning to its own and
coming up with something that it's a
good fit for its student body up to this
point in conclusion I'd like to just go
back to Alvar Aalto one of think a
telling quote for this and what she says
true architecture the real thing is only
where man stands in the center Altos
remarks remain as compelling today as
they were when they were spoken over
fifty years ago
here's one's perspective where one
stands in relation to the center or the
place architecture occupies in one world
one's worldview may shift but as we can
see in the vision of the founders
faculty and students we always return to
the same principles thank you
[Applause]
well being the one true technologist
here I'm only using notes this morning I
get very nervous whenever I'm asked to
speak to groups of artists and
architects and musicians and such people
because I don't know very much about the
subject but I always hearken back to one
of Victor Borges comments he used to
make which is he would introduce himself
as the music critic for mechanics
Illustrated so just kind of think of
that so with all this in mind I said to
Bill Mitchell yesterday bill what should
I say tomorrow this is a very important
forum and there's nothing worse than
somebody who actually doesn't know about
architecture learning a little bit of
the phrases and all that stuff and
standing up and pretending to know
something so bill said Chuck your job
tomorrow should be just to tell the
truth about what it takes to get
something like what we have accomplished
here done and I said bill tell the truth
you're not serious
and he said well tell a little bit of
the truth anyway so that's what I'm
going to try to do today is speak a
little bit of the truth of what we have
been through in this really last decade
when it comes right down to it because
it has been a remarkable adventure and I
want to begin saying that I suppose if
we sat down and made a list we could
probably identify a thousand people who
one way or another have had something
significant to do with the
transformation of the campus that is now
well underway and there would obviously
be a thousand different realities so I'm
only going to give you a bit of mine and
let me start with a couple of
observations and I will apologize in
advance for some of them when I had the
great privilege of coming here to MIT as
president in nine
eighteen ninety two things happened that
were sort of traumatic experiences one
is that I took my first drive down
Vassar Street and as you know I came to
MIT literally from the outside with a
great sense of reverence and awe for
what went on at this institution and I
could not somehow in my mind put
together what I saw on Vassar Street
with what I knew was the reality of the
institution and the second sort of weird
epiphany was during the interview
process they put me up in the suite on
the top of the Marriott looking down
over the campus by the way it was the
last time they put me up in anything of
that expense and I remember standing out
there looking down on top of the campus
from that height and distance and sort
of seeing all these rectilinear lines
with two big flag poles and for some
reason the image that kept coming into
my head was a naval base but then
there's the other side of the campus
after I came here every morning it's my
habit including this morning at about
6:30 to get up and go for a jog that's
how I get my mind in order for the day
and I absolutely fell in love and in awe
of the sight I would see every morning
running along the banks of the Charles
River and looking into the Killian Court
and the Bosworth buildings and cutting
back behind the dorms and going by Baker
house and so forth different everyday
different quality of light different
this at the other and so we had this
kind of juxtaposition of something awful
and something really quite wonderful and
yet
some level none of these seem to reflect
the wonderful extraordinary reality and
excitement electricity of what goes on
inside all of those buildings so with
this in my mind I formed a grand
well-organized vision of what I believe
this campus needed to be for the next 30
or 50 years started a capital campaign
to raise the funds knew the right
architects to hire and got the job done
so it will stand as my personal vision
and legacy
[Applause]
now of course none of that is true none
of that is true except for the first
three observations and just to tell you
how untrue it is I was remembering the
other day we have something here called
a campus visit where we have friends and
alumni and donors and so forth in to
meet faculty and students see what's
going on they always come to dinner at
the president's house at the end of the
the session and I always answer a few
questions and I remember the first year
somebody asked me the question you know
what's the situation with deferred
maintenance on campus and do you
anticipate building a new building for
something rather and so forth and I
distinctly remember that my answer was
understanding mi t--'s budgetary
situation and as best we could project I
did not believe that we would build a
building during my tenure well as it
turns out when I stepped down next fall
recognizing that a lot of the space I'm
going to refer to as in housing system
and so forth we will actually have
constructed about 25 percent of
everything on the MIT campus so much for
vision my good buddy and hero Gerhard
Kasper who was president of Stanford
during much of my tenure called up one
morning in his third year as president
and he said Chuck I just got unload on
somebody that if one more person asked
me what my vision for Stanford
University is I'm quitting because I
don't have a vision for Stanford
University and I really understand what
all that is about but having said that
let me make a few serious observations
we are as has been said much more
eloquently than I can say really in the
midst of a very profound transformation
of our campus
that I think of as an effort to better
reflect and support and inspire what the
extraordinary people this institution do
that to me is what it is all about and
well I don't know much literally about
architecture I do know a lot about
universities and I have sort of a basic
theorem about how universities great
ones at least evolve and when I say
evolve I mean intellectually and
socially as well as physically its kind
of happens roughly by 50% by planning
and strategy and at least 50% by
serendipity and opportunism and I use
opportunism in a positive sense of that
word it means faculty recognizing
exciting new intellectual or other
opportunities it's not like an orchestra
with a conductor despite the fact lots
of people like to write about themselves
or others as conductors it's more at
least here it's more of a jam session
among a lot of very talented musicians
who start kind of listening to each
other and get into the flow and people
like the provost and the executive vice
president you'll meet in a moment and
myself try to kind of keep all that
going see if we can get the right
musicians and listen to the pieces and
so forth and so on that's more to me the
way things happen the second serious
observation which being MIT I even did
as a plot one time of all the square
feet on this campus coming in and out
over the period since we moved across
the river from Boston the opportunity
for campus development the kind of thing
we're going through now it simply comes
in waves with a period of about 20 or 30
years and there are obviously good
seasons for that it's driven by two
things primarily I would say first and
foremost to be honest the economy
economy gets better you can do some
things economy gets worse you have to
pull back but juxtaposed on this are a
couple of things which are the
intellectual trends what faculty are
doing especially in the place it's
focused largely on science and
technology as we are here and secondly
some of the kinds of thinking that both
of the previous speakers referred to as
kind of views of what the life on a
campus should be how our students should
be what's the humanistic role and so
forth that also creates opportunities as
we moved forward so I think as we headed
into this sort of pivotal moment in
roughly 1997-98 through those two years
MIT and to a lesser extent I had what in
the sciences we often like to refer to
as the prepared mind there really was
not a well formed vision but there was a
lot of thinking about what is going on
in the world what's going on here that I
think put us in a good position when the
moment came and when I say the moment
means that literally in that sort of
two-year period of 97 98 it became
crystal clear that we had an opportunity
to create some things of historical
import in the development of MIT and I
say of MIT because we're not just
talking about physical facilities what
were some of the inputs to all of this
first of all while people were churning
out books about the end of science and
things like this the fact is we were
entering what I believe is the most
exciting period in science and
technology in
in history and so these enormous new
opportunities out there in terms of the
melding of the life sciences with the
physical sciences and the information
Sciences we started hearing more about
neuroscience and biology and nanoscale
science and technology and and on the
larger scale environmental issues
computational and systems biology all
these wonderful rapidly rapidly evolving
new areas in which people were coming
together across all kinds of
disciplinary boundaries to work very
very yeasty time and we're still very
much in the midst of that secondly there
was a very important report that was
finalized in 98 by a group that together
with Roz Williams who at that time was
our dean for education that I had
commissioned in 96 as a task force on
student life and learning it really was
to be sort of the next version of the
lost report that was referred to earlier
to think through what it was we owed to
these remarkable students here in terms
of their education and their experience
and that group came back someone
unexpectedly not focusing with a lot of
detail on what the intellectual content
should be but saying we've worked for
two years we've listened we've looked
we've talked to everybody and we think
that MIT needs to stop thinking about
itself as resting on two pillars of
teaching and research and start thinking
about itself as sitting on three columns
which they called academics research and
community a feeling that we had created
a separateness of our students in the
way in which they were housed and lived
from their learning environment in the
classrooms and laboratories and that we
really needed to become a better
integrated academic
unity that rapport we all swore was not
going to gather dust on a shelf and it
in fact drove a lot of our budget it
drove the way we restructured the
administration and a lot of it is
reflected in the things that are
beginning to happen now
architectural II on the campus there
were as also was alluded to rapidly
changing forces especially for MIT in
what it took to compete for the very
best students and underlying all of this
and it's a whole lecture in itself so I
will just mention it was a dramatic and
relatively rapid restructuring of our
finances as we moved out of an era in
which we were driven to a very unnatural
extent by federally sponsored research
to us a future in which we were going to
have a more balanced set of resources
drawing much more on the private sector
in the form of both industry and private
philanthropy so this kind of moment
arrived and I sort of knew what happened
to be what had to be done and we began
building a great team of people around
the administration kind of gave me a
little bit of a rejuvenation
moved into kind of a second phase of my
presidency and in 98 I published the
closest thing that anybody could claim
was an actual vision was a document
called the path to our future and that
document was not just personal thought
it was a reflection of what I was
hearing and learning from all kinds of
different directions in the institution
but it did kind of guide our pathway
forward but if you look back at that
document it's about core function it's
about what does it take to attract and
enable great faculty and great students
to do what they think is important and
to continue to be an institution that
does not look inward but looks outward
and always likes to take on big bold
challenges and influence the world
around it in many ways the adventure of
this campus transformation as it
properly should be is all about people
and it's about trying to seek out the
right balance of continuity and change
and we certainly have built on the years
of dedicated work of people like Bob sim
ha our campus planner for many many
years and Bill Dixon who was our senior
vice president when I came here and
there's a lot to allude back to and to
be grateful to them and as we began to
go about this transformation there was
one person who played a singular role
and to those people who do not like what
is going on on the campus I will refer
to Bill Mitchell as Rasputin to those
who like what's going on in the campus
and I certainly am among those I'd like
to say it's been an extraordinary
privilege to have Bill serve literally
as the architectural adviser to the
president and his wisdom and his balance
in not pushing things but showing
opportunity and how to think about
certain things
has meant a lot to me personally and
certainly means an enormous amount to to
the campus well kind of to move a little
bit toward closure here I want to just
comment on one thing which is sort of
emblematic of much of what was going on
here it was the process by which we
decided to ask Frank Gehry to design the
Stata Center and I'm sure this goes back
into the thousand people a thousand
realities but this one's the real
reality with the help of Bill Mitchell
and Vicky suriani and and so many other
wonderful people we had put together a
very formal process and we had selected
20-some architects to do what we knew
was an enormous ly important project to
to bid on it and I believe every one of
them responded and then a process was
set up that would end up with six
finalists - if you'll forgive me I will
classify as looking for two world-class
architects two really good architects
and two young and up and comers that was
kind of the goal and there was a
committee with which I was not really
even terribly deeply involved of faculty
and administrators who had gone through
all this narrowed it down to six and
then ultimately narrowed it down to two
and we sat around the conference table
when they were ready with their report
and I asked each person to tell me who
they thought we should select and why
and lo and behold literally 50/50 split
between two architects now as I implied
at the beginning of these remarks
president of the university may claim to
sit around the office and make lots of
decisions but the fact is you don't
really do it very often but here we had
one
and so I went down they sat in my office
around the coffee table with that
wonderful gentleman Bill Dixon who had
led construction here I think since he
was a freshman and who had a lot of
wisdom and I knew in my heart that I
wanted to go with Frank Gehry because I
knew we had to do something big and bold
and exciting and different and I figured
if I could convince bill that this was
the thing to do I would know that it was
the right decision so we chatted awhile
and I should have told bill my thinking
and in the way only he could do he
thought amendment said well let me tell
you something said back when the Kresge
Auditorium was designed it was
considered not I'm sorry not Kresge
Auditorium the chapel when the chapel
was designed it was considered so
radical that the foundation pulled their
funding from it and look at how we think
about it today so I said sounds like we
know who we need he said right let's go
guys did you make the call now at that
time what was the risk in my view the
risk was not whether Frank Gehry would
produce a remarkable and wonderful
facility for us the risk was would he
know how to listen to the clients in the
right way because I come back to the
main point I'm not interested in having
signature architects for the sake of
having signature architects and I don't
want something looking big and exciting
just to be big and exciting it's got to
reflect what we are and what we do and
above all it's got to be a place for
faculty and students to live and work
so after bill had called him ain't
called Frank up and we talked for about
25 minutes and about 24 of those minutes
was Frank telling me stories about
Richard Fineman now if any of you know
enough about physics to understand
richard fineman you would know that that
was signaling something to me about what
this guy really understands and he
clearly knew what the importance of
replacing building 20 was and so forth
and so I finally entered into that
particular phase of things with with a
great confidence that we would get what
we really wanted now a couple of beliefs
on my part again reflecting back to my
early years here basically during my
first year I sat down one day and had an
interesting talk with wonderful man
named Peter Rice
Peter rice headed the psychiatric
service in the MIT Medical Department
and he said to me one day you know MIT
is the best place in the world to be a
psychiatrist so I said what are you
talking about
and he said well I've worked on several
university campuses and other venues in
most places if you're a shrink people
come in and they come to see you and
they sort of turn up the collar their
overcoat and they look at their shoes
and they slouch down and it takes two or
three visits before they even get around
to saying what it is that's bothering
them but he said ever since I've been at
MIT people just kind of stride in my
office and they look in my eye and they
think well this is a professional just
like I am and I'll bet he's as good at
being a psychiatrist as I am at being a
computer scientist so they just tell me
what the trouble is and we go to work so
with kind of that in mind I came up with
a theory of how you should do campus
development which which I'm going to
term faith-based campus development
and what that means is you get the right
people for the right reason and you let
them do their job you have to have faith
in them so all of this to me is about
function not about monuments it's about
enabling and inspiring and respecting
and reflecting but also about raising
our sights and I deeply believe that the
things that have happened on this campus
with Simmons hall and the zessica Center
and the Stata Center and what you're
about to see volva ng in the brain and
cognitive science project and hopefully
in a couple others that are still on the
drawing boards it is going to raise our
sites as well as reflect and enable what
we do and it does in my mind and this is
one part I will be very serious about it
is all intended to reflect a great
boldness and confidence in our future
but I want to tell you and I think this
is the truth part that bill wanted me to
come out with it's been hard it is not
an easy task I transformed myself into
what I think of as a snapping turtle
namely once we got moving to accomplish
these things I had to sort of just grab
on to people and things by the ankle and
not let go until we got done there are
so many constituencies as you can
imagine faculty students trustees alumni
donors the federal government they all
come into play and there are enormous
forces and the two forces that I think
caused the deepest angst and biggest
problem with accomplishing something
wonderful and extraordinary as is
happening today are first the economy
that is clear
we started into this we were enabled to
become bald and do some things in a
relatively short period of time because
the economy was going up but lo and
behold just about the time we got well
into it the economy went down and you
can imagine the things that that creates
you have to really persevere secondly
something I read a long time ago
in all places in a chapter in Henry
Kissinger's autobiography he used a term
debilitating nostalgia and I kept
wondering for years what does that mean
because quite frankly I'm a nostalgic
person in my the way I think about my
life and so forth but in the years both
of Michigan and here as an academic
administrator I came to understand what
I think that term really meant and there
is this weird balance you have to find
between looking backward in the right
way to understand your heritage and
where your strength comes from as an
institution and what needs to have some
continuity and not getting so caught up
in it but you don't do the really
exciting forward-looking things and I've
been debating since I sat down this
morning to put these notes together
whether to say the following or not but
I think I am going to say it about two
years ago maybe a little more as our
building program was getting underway
we took the academic council and a few
other friends around to visit everything
under construction and as I was leaving
one of my colleagues said to me this
must really make you happy to see all
this going on
and I looked at him and I said the truth
is this has been so hard and so painful
to keep going that I don't feel very
happy right now but having said that
yesterday yesterday we wandered around
in the sunshine with faculty and
students and donors on one of some of
these marvelous outdoor spaces on Frank
Stata Center and I can tell you it has
all been worthwhile and I'm feeling just
great thank you
[Applause]
well welcome back and and it thanks to
the speakers this morning who really set
up this discussion in a terrific way and
an interesting name tag here on the
front it says William Mitchell on the
back it says rescue let me just jump in
with a couple of quick words that might
be useful to set up the discussion and
then I'm going to ask well two of two of
the architects I admire most in the
whole world to to say what they what
they're here to say today and I think
we'll get some interesting discussion
going you know as I say was listening to
Chuck describing the process that we've
gone through over the last few years one
thing Kant kept coming back to me was
that MIT is an enormous ly critical
place and nothing around here gets taken
for granted nothing goes unquestioned
and that's that's the beauty and the
quality of the place and the thing that
attracts so many of us into this
community I think and something that's
been consistent right through the
process of rethinking the campus and
doing the individual buildings has been
a constant desire to take each
opportunity that came along as a moment
for critically rethinking to critically
rethink what a laboratory can be to
critically rethink what housing can be
in the twenty twenty first century
housing for students to try to
understand how the world is changing how
this campus is changing how one might
respond in some new and important ways
and that attitude of not taking anything
for granted and rethinking each project
rethinking the premises of each project
from the beginning has been I think
fundamental to what we've done and
there's been an attitude that all the
way through we're conducting a series of
experiments and the is all of the
scientists and engineers
here no you only really learn something
from bold experiments you don't learn
all that much from experiments that
don't really put something out on the
table that can be argued about that can
be debated that potentially is
contentious so what we've gone through
is a set I think of very bold urbanistic
and architectural experiments where
we've tried to lay out some visions of
what the future can be and what it's
generated it's much to my gratification
has been a huge amount of debate each
project we've done has done that so what
we really need to what what I expect
will we'll do this morning is continue
that debate and so I'm going to ask
Frank to jump in and say some words
about how he sees the process of campus
building and what we've done here and
what happened to the particular project
and I'm going to ask Bob who who
promises to be grouchy and I have no
doubt that he'll deliver on his proj
profit promise and then we'll see where
it goes and take it from there so then
I'll ask we have a couple of very
interesting respondents who I'll ask a
certain point to come in and we will
leave some time for questions from the
audience so frame well I'm I'm with
Chuck fest I'm sort of a faith-based
practitioner and I assumed that if if I
ask enough questions when I'm engaged
with a project and I'm dealing with
people that are thinking about their
environment what they want what they
need that I will come away with up with
a road map or a path to which to respond
now I don't come to the table with a
preconception if I knew I've said this a
million times but if I knew exactly what
I was going to do I would
do it because I'd already thought it
through and and seen the results and
decided whether it's good or bad and
then I go forward so in the case of this
project the excitement for me was and
the reason I guess I brought up Fineman
is in talking to chuck was that richard
fineman represented that kind of
curiosity and the cat playing with the
ball of twine attitude that that you
would just sort of take things as they
are given to you respond and work on
them and assume that that that there was
some kind of you could participate in
some way with the knowledge that you
bring to the table I suppose I was
raised on some kind of Talmudic
discussions with my grandfather and if
you've gotten into the - any of that
it's all about questioning and why and
then you make a statement and then he
made he makes a counter statement and
then you go but it's a constant inquiry
and constant it seems totally relevant
while you're doing it but it's it's it's
sort of Holmes you're thinking and
sooner or later he come back come up
with an essence in the case of the
Talmud the final essence is the Golden
Rule
and everything comes back to that in
some way I believe that I'm doing that
with my buildings following that golden
rule that I want to be a good neighbor
that I respect the other architects
whose work surround me some of it I like
some of it I don't like
and there is a growing model of urbanism
in in America I guess in the world and
it's it's optimistically believe it has
something to do with democracy that
there's plural a pluralist notion and
that there's a collision of ideas which
again is Talmudic and that the collision
of ideas is the is the process by which
you you come to conclusions yourself you
make a statement and you hope that that
it's has positive effects the the
collage of parts at the Stata Center I
can take I should probably do this is go
around Cambridge and take pictures
showing you that there's an
extraordinary precedent for everything
I've done and that we just don't think
of it that way you don't think of you
think of buildings as individual
buildings and if you look around you'll
see that they are really pieces of
buildings collage Don each other you
don't see the whole buildings and that
they create a kind of a urbanism and
that I was I was just continuing that
the the the program the Stata Center is
a huge huge building compared to others
on campus and I was trying to break down
its scale and and humanize it I made
many studies of what it what it would be
just as a simple block which would have
fit more into the campus as it was
that wasn't why I was brought here and
as we responded breaking down the mass
of that the user group seemed to respond
positively the interiors of this
building are not finished finite
interiors they are a know a very
open-ended system the idea is that the
rugged individualists hsihu are
inhabiting it are going to enter
intervene they're going to bring their
stuff in they already have and over time
this building will change and become
become theirs it's I believe it's strong
enough to survive that but we'll see
I don't think everybody's gonna like it
I think at the beginning the the the
complaints I've heard so far are all
fixable they all relate mostly relate to
they don't have the privacy that they
they want everybody would want a private
office with a view and close to the
bathroom or something
that wasn't possible but I think over
time it could be it could be completely
enclosed into private offices and if
they decide to go that way I've you know
a lot of positive feeling in the
meetings yesterday but we'll see over
time whether it really works and and I
hope it does and you can't use your cell
phones in there and I suppose I'm going
to get blamed for that but we've created
a Faraday Faraday cage I didn't want to
create a Faraday cage okay Bob go go for
it
[Laughter]
okay it was explained that we were to be
each of us was to be a member of a
discussion group and not to give a
lecture but I what I want to say is so
complex and contract and contradictory I
guess that that I've written it down as
notes and I'm afraid it's going to be
kind of like a sermon for about five
minutes I hope you'll forgive me and as
I have pointed out that I'm gonna be a
bit grouchy and it's gonna be a little
embarrassing but I'm gonna be saying in
some ways and so those of you who want
to do afterwards you are you are invited
to do that but I also just mentioning
that our son Jim is a great fan of a
friend of a a Frank and I want to make
sure that all my any friend here doesn't
mention the Jim that I have said a few
negative things about him and also don't
mentioned to my wife and partner that
I'm using notes because she says he
should not you should speak
spontaneously but I want to get a lot of
in a lot in real quickly so if you I
will go being grouchy there's no
question that there is a great
commitment to the idea of cutting edge
at MIT especially but to any academic
institution in general but I would think
it is important for an architect for an
academic institution to employ cutting
edge as a product and not so much an
image a cutting edge that engages work
and is not necessarily a place also it
is where the campus is a community as
the president has mentioned
and if I maybe be mean and this is
happening a lot elsewhere there were the
where the campus is a community and not
a stage set which cutting edge can
connect with we're cutting edge can
happen in context but it but much should
not necessarily be as context it should
not be all over we're cutting age the
cutting edge derived by a vital action
and not necessarily by architectural via
architectural form where it happens
within the uses of the building and not
sort of has happened where creativity
derives from communication on one hand
aware or let's say we're community
derives from and creativity let's say
creativity the derives from
communication on one hand within the
community on the other hand very much on
focus it's likely the users who want to
not be in open offices perhaps and there
is this inevitable kind of a wonderful a
kind of contradiction and conflict it is
a community for communication but also
there must be focused and these must be
accommodated and therefore it should
there should be a setting which is not
distractive which is not just intrusive
via very often cutting-edge architecture
should be recessive and not as and a lot
of architecture today is this in general
let's call it a dramatic abstract and
also kind of industrial symbolically
that's a it's a kind of an irony in this
era but abstract expressionism involving
very often what I call industrial rokai
I'm getting pretty bad here huh
in a setting where dynamic change
happens rather than is expressed
therefore because I think there really
is a danger in in making a background
that is intrusive as I said also via an
architecture that accommodates
flexibility that is extremely important
and it is a place for functions
naturally an accommodation to variations
in functions over time spatial
mechanical electronic and therefore you
could say not where form follows
function but where forms accommodate
functions and the plural therefore an
architecture often in the case can work
that's in the tradition of the
vernacular loft building and I think
this is something we've tried we've
tended to forget where there is certain
precedent and tradition natural
especially in New England there is a
wonderful industrial mill building there
is the academic loft there is a long
tradition as was pointed out by Jim
Ackerman of going way back to wave and
Mary to Nassau Hall Princeton to Harvard
Hall at Harvard where the buildings were
made as lofts in the sense to
accommodate varying leases over time and
the building's still have iconic quality
on the outside but also are
accommodating inside there's also
another kind of building of that sort
which is the Verna which is a the
Italian Palazzo over three or four
hundred years from the renaissance
through baroque it's essentially the
same kind of building with the Cortile
in the middle that could ever time
evolve from
the residence of a of a dynastic family
to a library of a an embassy a a museum
over time so I think someone therefore
could say and I remember the in the
Richards tower that also was on the
screen up here and I remember that when
we did our first many decades ago
Princeton our first building a first
laboratory building I was very aware of
the Richard Serra's being not a building
that was appreciated by the users it
again had this sort of dramatic quality
within articulations formal
articulations that did not allow for
flexibility and I mentioned this
approach that I would like to use to the
the the head of the department of
molecular biology who would be occupying
the building and he said oh I very much
agree with you that building went up
when I was a graduate student at Penn
and I was one of the vigorous
antagonists who used that building and
held up signs against it and I don't
want to say something wrong again mean
about the week on but I think it is
significant that they done asked that
they lost building does have valid
validity so you can say you can say down
with architecture as boring originality
I heard someone say that the other day
boring originality and I think you could
say I even in your presence Michelangelo
and Pilate oh we're good
rather than original Michelangelo's dome
had really been established by by
Brunelleschi you could say a century
before that it was not signature it was
not ego centric it was good I could say
also down with the old romantic idea of
the artist as as original in order to
be good you can also they said say
therefore Viva Convention and vernacular
architecture as convention where the
architect in a Mannerist way works to
tweak convention rather to invent new
conventions
Viva architecture that acknowledges the
technology of today and it is an irony
that much of the architecture that gave
out today these sort of macabre Larry
and architectural vocabulary that is
essentially based on an industrial
vocabulary which is passe it's a kind of
a it also it reuses the not-not-not
viewers by any means but reuses the are
Kathy the architect the architecture of
of modernism of fifty years ago and the
revival of modernism of fifty years ago
it's a little like just as historical is
reviving the Renaissance of five hundred
years ago whatever so architecture that
acknowledges the technology of today
electronics not passe industrial in the
post-industrial age about sustainability
rather than style of structure and this
is again electronics very approved for
the I'm almost at the end for the for
the electronic age so Alba old-fashioned
modernist abstract articulated form Viva
perhaps iconographic surface iconic
imagery and architecture is important to
create identity and even the Nassau Hall
type of building has iconic quality to
create identity but yes it should not a
the iconic quality should not dominate
and therefore be distracting as I said
so identity via dynamic iconography
perhaps rather than sculptural form
valid shelter rather than
the sculpture I'm talking about a lot of
the architecture currently of today
which we are reacting against then
there's also the issue of respecting the
budget we can I think that should be
considered as extremely significant a
fundamental of that and I think an
institution should do that respect the
budget because the budget also has to go
to other important aspects of the
institution so respect the budget and
and make it not at the mercy of vision I
wrote a book a while back that had an
essay in it called this is awful the
vision thing why it sucks
but I can mention it here because the
MIT press published it and I said if you
want to change that and make that more
correct you can do that he said that guy
said no don't do that one last little
ending I want to put here is my
particular love for the original MIT
building and you can say oh well that's
what you've been arguing against isn't
it I mean but in a way I call it the
good the great complex the original
billing we're doing some interior work
in that in a sense what you can say it
is a building on the outside which is a
very much an iconic grandiose kind of
gesture if you will and only inside if
just amazingly down-to-earth vernacular
kind of industrial space of that period
which can accommodate non-distracting
environment and flexibility over time
for uses and changes that can happen in
the spatially and mechanically and later
electronically I loved referring to it
we were being interviewed for the job
and I thought oh god we're not going to
get the job as a transvestite kind of
building
which is on the outside wearing clothes
that are different from the body inside
but very very appropriate and then I
also Dow whatever I say Elva refer to
elbow altitude Baker hall they are you
have a precedent here which i think is
very good so excuse my being kind of
nasty excuse my being a bit preachy but
I will end on with kind of Aviva
pragmatism okay
thank you
we do this all the time when he rags on
me his his son finds out and makes him
call me and apologize what happened to
les is bored
well you evolve you evolve and as as
work in institution should evolve
architects involved and they evolve also
as a result I loved your emphasis on you
didn't use the word but you might have a
dialogue of working with a client in
that way and we very much enjoy that we
get we say we get we get some of our
best idea we get we get our best ideas
from our clients and also I love the
idea of layering not always an agreement
with your kind of layering but I think
the idea of layering it's very important
look Corbusier did it beautifully in a
building I adore they've either savoir
you have the exterior and then inside
you could all sorts of different things
happening then peeking my mother's house
does that someone love it's it's
appropriate and can be used in different
ways but this isn't really the subject
is it our work is very different as you
know
but but today he sounded like you're
fitting well into the resurgence of
fundamentalism oh my god like I should
vote for Bush I think you know I don't
have a I'm not an evangelist for
anything and I don't really believe I
don't want people to copy me or do what
I do or any of that stuff and I'm really
not interested in creating a school
school of Gary isms I've had strangely
enough there's been a kind of a nice
response from people to some of my
buildings like in Bilbao which by the
way respected the budget
listen to the client and paid for itself
in the first eight months of its
existence those were all I didn't expect
that to happen but those are all very
positive things and when I go to Bilbao
little old ladies come up and touch me
the younger ones don't I don't
but there has been a very positive
response to it if you know if the
marketplace does and that's something
that you talked about in your writings
we for years that it is behooves us to
somehow connect with the world around us
and and I think some of my buildings do
not all of them I'm not sure about this
one
the the response has been overwhelmingly
positive in some cases and I look at
them and I'm not sure what they're
liking about it usually but I think I do
represent some kind of a humanist
attitude that I try to connect with the
scale of people and and I respond to the
time and place that I'm in and so I
would I get nervous when when I feel
like you're apologizing for talent in
some way you're you're demeaning it and
and I don't think you mean to do them no
I just think talent it does not involve
originality it does not you can also be
someone involved in evolution rather
than revolution I think they're very
much in this period where oh to be
cutting edge cutting edge means
revolution I guess and and but there's
an awful lot of appropriate evolutionary
evolution is also what's appropriate and
what's not I mean if you take it
everywhere is they're rebuilding I can
only speak for myself I probably hate
most of the buildings you hate probably
oh yeah
so easy
and and I think borrow meanie was an
egomaniac of some kind wasn't he so ego
plays a role it's just that it it's
tempered so much by
you know you get budget you got client
you got building department you got
processes you got what's what's what's
available in building you have context
you have there are so many constraints
on any ego trip somebody may and bark on
that that the the the amount of freedom
to to express in in any architectural
project isn't that that great so I don't
think even you know if I make ten more
buildings like this one it's not going
to destroy the fabric of America
so it's not dangerous and it might be
positive let me raise something else
here pretty good made a pretty good
start on picking apart one part of the
title of this forum which is cutting
edge so we've matured architects and I
hate the Bilbao effect and I hate all
this so we did that now the other part
of the the title was patron and and
that's an interesting word and Jim
Ackerman could say a great deal about
the the idea of patron but but of course
it's very rough metaphor for what goes
on in these days because it's really
engagement of a community that there may
have been a time there was a time when
university presidents played the kind of
role of Pope's and princes of the past I
think Chuck can confirm for us that this
is not what university presidents do
these days and the process of making
architecture is very much a process of
engaging an incredibly complicated
community is Frank just alluded to and
there's many facets some full of
contradictions and different goals and
different ways of articulating what's
what's in what's important to them and
then there's a distinction between the
community as it exists now that can
express itself and you can respond to
but of course you're making buildings
for community that's going to be here
I'm 20 years hence a hundred years
handsome and so somehow buildings have
to respond in some way to some some
sense of what what the future may hold
sometimes we've seen that's very
successful so as Bob as pointed help the
old old main conflict here at MIT the
Wills Bosworth buildings have gone
through extraordinary transformations of
function over the years and have been
robust enough to live them transform and
still remain extremely successful
buildings but I'd love to hear some
comments
you thought from both of you on this
issue of you know the nature of a client
these days the nature of a community and
how what kind of process one can
successfully go through in engaging them
well I think the Frank did mention the
the complexity the clients now or our
multiple clients not as you said not the
Duke or they poop or whatever they're
very important the idea of client and
patron architects cannot exist without
that because you know painter can paint
maybe he's or she is starving while
they're painting but at least they can
do it we can't get our buildings built
without without we can't get our art
accomplished without the patron and the
client and the difficulties today are
the complexity of the client very often
the client is a committee or it's
several committees and there's arguments
within the committee's and then there of
course the the government agencies and
so forth that you have to connect with
it's the kind of Byzantine complexity
I'm hoping we're not in a Byzantine era
just before they fall of the Byzantine
Empire corresponding to that but the
complexity is enormous and that is very
very difficult not actually having an
individual client can be difficult too
but the most wonderful thing is to have
a client or a client group that you that
that you can connect can connect with
and I won't say much more except that
the it is a very difficult relationship
because on one hand the client is paying
you you are in a sense of servant of the
client on the other hand your name is to
be on the building you are to be
identified with what is built so you
can't do something that you disagree
with so there's a sort of a built-in
extreme difficulty there at the same
time we had a very difficult client
in England and as a matter of fact in
that same book there was another essay
where I wrote described the difficulties
of that particular building that we were
having and I said particularly we had
great difficulty with the with the Lord
I'm gonna be a lord in England and then
I had written in there the Lord and the
great difficulty and then I read thank
God we won the Revolutionary War and
then I removed it from the front when it
was being edited but it I noticed it's
bat was back in the book and I think
again the MIT press were and said oh
let's leave that in but about a week two
weeks ago I met this character again and
he was so friendly and out of the
building with such a masterpiece and
blah blah that's very so these things
are very complex but there is just an
inevitable complex complex there where
you are working for somebody that you
have to accommodate just lastly I think
there really has to be a kind of feeling
of trust that is so important mutual
trust mutual understanding we don't
agree but we trust each other
I remember one job it got to a certain
point where I could say no in these
meetings now I didn't I don't have to
worry about coming out with some stupid
ID in the meeting and that they will
lose faith in me because sometimes free
stupid ideas can lead to good ideas in
the in the dialogue and the dialogue you
must you have to be just open and try
out all different things when you're
talking so this is a very complex answer
again to a very complex complex question
but we all of us need the equivalent of
our Lorenzo de Medici I don't believe
the sound of one hand clapping makes a
building you didn't you need the
interaction with the client and for me
the process of built working with with
the client is the most exciting part of
what I do
even better than the end product and I
discovered that I wasn't kidding myself
when I thought that or thinking that
because there are three buildings I can
tell you about that I worked on that I'm
very proud of that I've never been to
sea because in each case the client and
I the people who I worked with
disappeared it wasn't my fault that they
disappeared they got fired or something
but in the case of the Iowa laser lab
building which the worked with a laser
scientist and a new president came in
and fired him so I didn't go I never
went to the opening I never still have
never seen the building only in photos
same thing happened with big industrial
thing I did in Sacramento for Herman
Miller and they had a the building was
under construction they had a shift
total shift and management and
everything and I just never went I've
seen photographs of it
I think it's been torn down already but
look there are a few cases where I've
worked with clients where the client the
main person disappeared and and you're
left with their surrogate and then six
months later the big the big cheese
comes back and since they haven't been
involved in the evolution of your
designs and the back-and-forth between
the press setting the priorities and
they look at it and they think god
that's strange I don't like that and
something so I insist I won't take it
project unless I always ask is so-and-so
going to be able to come in into the
room at some point and evaluate what
we've done and when they say yes I say
well if that person isn't in on at least
50% of the process so that I get to meet
them on a regular basis as the project
evolves them I'm not going to accept
this commission in the case of MIT I had
access to the president he was available
I didn't bother him but I knew that at
some point he had to say yes or no and I
didn't want him to be sandbagged I
wanted him to understand what we were
doing why we were doing it what the
priorities were what what we chose as a
priority over what we dismissed this as
another priority and that this
evaluation process has been serious and
and and so he knew that it wasn't a
trivial or nothing up kind of a
idiosyncratic ego thing that I was
imposing with no with no rationale in
the case of the Stata Center we had I
think close to 700 clients became clear
to me in the beginning that we had all
the faculty senior faculty junior
faculty we had the administration led by
Chuck we had the the advisory group led
by Bill and we had 400 plus students and
MIT students are rugged individualists
they don't they come here to what they
believe is an open society to where
they're gonna be free thinkers and they
express themselves right from the
beginning
and so we created a website and put all
of our work on the website all of our
thinking as we went along
continuously on the website and the
first six months I got hate mail
including a lot of suspicion from from
the senior faculty thinking that we
don't really need an architect we just
want our office exactly the way it is
and don't bother me with this
architecture stuff and the suspicion
that I my ego trip was going to use up
the budget and in and sacrifice the
things that they hold near and dear and
to them and I think we went through
quite a quite a bath of fire from them
as to and testing constantly to make
sure we weren't doing that to the point
where we got close to the final
conclusion and these very people started
saying well have we have we prevented
any great ideas have we have we stopped
you from being have you have you had
enough freedom have you you know that
kind of stuff so we knew that there was
a pretty good balance of by the time we
got there and I don't think it's a
perfect building they aren't perfect and
I'm not perfect but the what I treasure
most is that client relationship and the
people the friends I've made in in
working on the project and it's like I'm
gonna have postpartum blues I'm sure I
always do
well dislike you're so right that when
there's a change in administration half
through the jaw that can be disaster we
perfectly the new administration tends
to say our what our predecessors are
jerks and their architects were jerks
and it's it's a very sad situation that
does happen and that's again part of the
complexity yeah you know a big part of
the complexity that I've certainly seen
from the inside over the last decade is
the the way that institutional dynamics
evolved in very complicated ways Chuck
talked about this the way the economy
evolves and the way other things
developed it makes it extremely
difficult to keep clarity and
consistency and stick-to-itiveness about
the things that are really important and
we we I have to say I'm not an enormous
debt of gratitude to Chuck who really is
just been determined through this
building program to to do it right and
and and this is one of the roles that's
absolutely critical in in big
institutions of course the university is
a big institution these days has to be
somebody in the process just process is
prepared to stand up when the going gets
really really tough as it does in these
process and so you know we made a
commitment to do this right there's an
important principle here and we're going
to follow through on it so it's a
crucial thing there's one thing little
anecdote about our building the people
that inhabit our building are the some
of the most creative scientists alive on
earth and they create robotics and
artificial intelligence and so rod
Brookes the leader of that group when we
when I met with him was one day telling
me about his fantasy for his office he
said I'm gonna walk in and say call
professor Smith and on the wall there
would be a picture immediately of
professor Smith and they could discuss
each other and professor Smith would
have a picture of him and he could tell
his room to temperatures too low
and it could do everything without
touching anything he could do it all by
voice activation and then another one
gave me all the sound gadgetry and all
the interconnective gadgetry and things
that he or she had and I went through
this and then we got to the finale when
we had a meeting with all of these
people talking about the light switches
and the thermostats and things in their
office and I presumed that I was going
to get a bunch of this stuff and they
all wanted the same hold light switches
and the ordinary no voice activated
nothing he didn't want any I think as
being very interesting in the process
that we've gone through and this is the
whole process of construction and
engagement of the the contractors the
construction workers the the crafts of
construction were the most moving things
over the last few weeks as this project
has come together this Frank's project
as a stator has come together has been
the number of we all have anecdotes like
this of construction workers who've just
buttonholed us as we've gone around the
site and said you know we're so proud of
what we've done here we came from other
jobs to work on this project you know we
we felt we were part of an enterprise
that was really making making something
special in the community and this is
very different of course from Palladio's
day as Jim Ackerman can explain in great
detail and Palladio was a Mason he went
out on horseback and and supervised
construction sites in the most direct
direct kind of way now we have
amazing contractual complexities we have
extraordinary supply change to organize
we have the thousands of people involved
and division into different crafts and
knowledge about how to make things
distributed geographically across the
world so it's tremendously complicated
thing to engage and what's particularly
complicated I think is to to get the
spirit of pride in construction and the
sheer joy of making things and the
knowledge that you know resides in the
heads of people who actually do make
things into the process and one of the
things being important about about this
particular project I think there's been
a lot of innovation in how you think
about doing this and I'd be very
interested in the comments you know both
of you might have on how do you think
about that how do we go about as we go
forward making more buildings get that
spirit into the process well I just a
question about the growing complexity
and the you look at someone gave me once
a set of the reproduction of the of the
note of the what I want the part of the
contract of Sir Edwin Lutyens for a
house they written part specifications
to work out what the specifications for
a great mansion and that he built and
the specifications were about five pages
and today any any building could have
specifications that much and maybe
several volumes and so the the the
complexities is enormous but I think
even worse than that is the fact that
you cannot do what Palladio do is to go
out to the site partly because the site
maybe is in another and isn't another a
continent but you cannot get there and
say oh that is a little too big let's
change it it has to be absolutely
established on the drawings or no matter
good you are as an architecture you
can't anticipate everything the thing is
seeing the thing in real scale in three
dimensions and there what an opportunity
that we have lost when when when they
when the architect no longer could be a
he's kind of a yeah he's sort of a
lawyer sort of making the specifications
of the drawings where the architect can
not be a worker so to speak on the site
and to make some modifications and
changes as it evolved and that is a real
shame and a lot of that has to do with
details the form of the building you can
pretty much established in your mind by
models and drawings but the actual
quality of the detail in the scale of
the details can it's the hardest thing
to do and you cannot go on the side and
change it once in a while you can on one
building we did many years ago I said oh
my god this was a real mistake and it
actually involved I think 9 million
dollars it was a big job with nine
million dollars and I told the client
that if he would do that I would happen
to be on Trafalgar Square
I would three times cross Trafalgar
Square on my knees in a what did they
wear what kind of coats did they wear in
those days when you were haired to hair
to do that and he very nicely said you
don't have to do that we'll pay for it
but that seldom can happen and that
again is a question of a detail that you
did not anticipate and so it's the
complexity and not being able to be
Palladio and go on the site and then
change you know that you don't have that
trouble but you can you know the details
well we've been using software for the
aircraft industry Katya and for quite a
number of years and we we bumped into it
kind of accidentally because
I started using curves and curves were
hard to represent to the construction
industry so that that you could
demystify it so that they could be built
and so you could bid on it in a rational
way and that process of doing that has
taught me that the our profession our
architectural profession has been infant
alized by overprotection by the and it's
not it's logical you I joined the AIA
years ago and the air I joined it for
protection because there was a an in
place culture and and legal process that
the courts recognized and so you could
work and feel kind of safe from
financial ruin because of some mistake
you might make the computer and that
process has led to the architects being
everybody's had this experience where
the building always comes in over by
something although sometimes we've come
in under but the contractor will say to
the owner if you straighten that curve
I'll save you a million bucks and the
owner who doesn't have the extra spare
million has to accede to that for and so
the architect becomes marginalized in a
split second and everybody's experience
that and the client doesn't want you to
be marginalized because they want you to
deliver what you have but they don't
know how to make it make you deliver
what
there that's intangible to them the
computer does change the game and and
creates a such a precise definition of
the parts and pieces that the contractor
I found when they're confronted with
this barrage of precision are are quite
happy they really want to to have that
and they don't they feel much safer and
so instead of looking at something that
doesn't look like anything they've done
and doubling the bid and they take it
seriously and they spend time in in the
early stages and develop a fairly
precise cost response so it leads to
better cost control and it leads to the
architect being able to take more
responsibility which makes them a better
partner with the client because the
client wants you to be parental not
infantile and and if you keep the more
you can become that the more likely your
you know you're going to achieve the
goals of your own and the client and I
think that's what was different in in
when we refer back to Pilate oh and to
the they were the master builders they
had control of the of the whole
construction site and and were respected
and were treated parentally as the
parent and unlike what what's happened
today so I think we as architects should
should really analyst II we're where
this technology can take us and use it
and
I think that's been something well built
and I've been working on stuff like this
for some years now yeah maybe it's about
20 yeah let me and we've had two
respondents who've been taking notes and
I think probably have some interesting
things to to say at this point so let me
invite up to the podium and young pack
and John Kerry to say a few words and I
want to leave us time sure their
questions bubbling up in the audience so
after the remarks from a respondent
I'm glad to be here just a chance to
speak and I have taken some notes down
and as a respondent my task was to
respond to what I've been hearing here
today this morning I've I have taken
some notes but mostly I think is a kind
of an extension from what has been
accomplished here at MIT and I
understand about five years of capital
campaign to shape the future of MIT
there of course there's a discussion
about signature buildings and so forth
and I think that it's I hope that
started building will be able to help
recruit the investment in saying a lot
of time as you were able to do it in
Spain and and what that what that really
means that that the building was not
only a signature building but it was a
sign of some sort and this could like
kind of take the learning from Las Vegas
to learning from mr. Frank Gehry about
building as a sign and unlike the ball
where the investment comes back in the
forms of tourism and
financial investment into what was a
relatively deprived city at the time I
think in the MIT situation that it would
come to some form of enrollments and
philanthropy as was suggested by mr.
Ackerman before what that kind of leads
me to my thinking about is respondent is
that what this building and these built
new buildings and what a new image
building of MIT would have in relation
to outside of these buildings at MIT
into the larger part of the world that
would be generated my thought about
responding and also to Architecture in
general I feel like I would like to just
kind of say something about movement in
architecture because there was also
apparent that there was a movement in
architecture through the history of MIT
campus development and buildings and as
I was yesterday touring the new
buildings with Jane
I started looking at building new
buildings a little bit closely and one
thing I realized that was that the
buildings are often completed I mean
they're open public to open the public
even the occupancy to use of the
building before it's actually completed
that happens a lot and then there is
also buildings also fall apart before
they're actually completed
and then there's always a kind of a
tendency among some of us and in general
public that the architecture or building
looks better when is under construction
or in my case of my experience under
destruction and then it would be
followed by renovations and
modifications and adaptations that
obviously you know that is part of
architecture but that brings a question
about whether the building would ever be
complete and and this idea of notion of
whether the completeness is illusion or
reality is a completeness now obsolete
or even may have never existed in
history at all
then I looked back then I extend from
here to campus as a city and what if the
campus is a small version of city then I
would I'm interested in thinking about
what is the contemporary issues of
urbanism today and that would help me to
understand the campus as a city I forgot
to start time in my clock I have 15
minutes but I have ten minutes now so as
far as I know right now in my basis the
most popular issues of urbanism today
really two things the most popular
that's I seem to be talking about one is
shrinking cities and this is the
condition that is developing among it's
almost like a diploma for a developed
nation once it achieved economic level
that it started to accumulate shrinking
cities meaning cities that depopulate
significant way economically otherwise
actually United States is the number one
contributor to your sentences fifty
percent of contemporary city
exist in us of course most of them is
north east and the middle west and
majority the rest of it exist in Western
Europe and I'm sorry
yeah Western Europe well these come from
declining of a birth rate as well as the
aging of a population which in some
extent is us had exempted that from that
to the best amount of immigration
policies but countries like Germany
currently almost 80 million people will
be down to 56 million at year 2050 a
totally 57 million will be down to about
26 million this causes a situation where
cities are able to sustain itself
economically its infrastructure and
services in fact now that German
government is it's recognizing that is
not just about issues changing cities
it's really about a changing nation and
I think that we would have to be equal
to prepare for that as well then there
is another urban issues it's called
informal cities I really think that
everybody should see a great and very
important exhibition at least center
right now my article posted whose work
has developed as an artist aspects of
informal cities throughout the world
particularly in Latin America in Eastern
Europe these talk about the movement of
basically mobility of capital and labor
in which that architecture and city is a
significant part of that oftentimes
victims of their situation in Americas
for instance even in the not even 20
years ago the center of population moves
approximately about something like 50
inches to the south and 28 inches to the
west every day
and this explains about a very
interesting situation about architecture
and City as a basically form or moving
element in other words cities are moving
and an architecture have to be prepared
to move as well and what's next I had
taken too many notes here that I would
like to maybe make one more thing about
this is that there is another movement
about architecture that I have come to
recognize is that architecture has
politics in the 80s
architecture was rather pretty symbolic
to the idea of hope and optimism in the
future such as the buildings like AT&T
building Battery Park City Canary Wharf
television City they were on the
magazines and news media as somewhat
very positive new brilliant and and
coherent but the 90s these have changed
architectures no longer exists in that
way we have seen buildings through waco
Sarajevo Oklahoma City Chechnya a couple
twice Baghdad twice American embassies
and most part of the world and of course
you know about the New York City and
what has becomes that architecture is is
a the new political effigy for social
political economic discontent against
basically the authority from the
dominant sector of the globe and so the
buildings are being shot exploded and
burned and collapsed this is a kind of a
new situation for architecture and it
leads to the question of the future and
as a mr. president investors explain
path to the future is the way that this
capital this program was developed and I
was just kind of wondering whether if
there was a path to future we is then
there must be a future to get to but
then I also know about another world
world words that are famous
from perhaps from places like here which
is called the future is now and I look
at that as a kind of a different way
which is I feel like that is in a sense
a kind of a sense of a total command of
future by the present and the absence
that were leads to an absence of future
which we hate we may have used up now
already meaning that we have depleted
the future like it would deplete fuel
petroleum-based fuel so I feel in some
times that future is obsolete which is a
very very negative attitude I realized
and I hope that like for instance with
the WTC rebuilding I was more interested
in instead of rebuilding it with what we
already know and can do I was interested
if someone would discover a new life
that was born there that did not exist
before the collapse weather is an
organism or a matter but maybe there was
something that came to new life that
never existed in the world from that
event and that this would be a way of
building and bringing back to the new
kind of a future so I hope that
architecture is can be part of bringing
back to the future
the idea of regaining hope and even will
and the will even the mere possibility
exists further even for a year a day or
a second from now so that's my
responsibility
[Applause]
for putting a little bit of space
between me and that very vigorous
conversation between Bob venturi and
Frank Gehry I was worried for a moment I
was listening in the audience carefully
from the viewpoint of someone who
participates in the thinking about the
campus as a whole even as we think about
individual buildings and individual
designers as someone who is responsible
in working with our president and
provost and many staff members of the
campus to actually oversee the
management of the construction the
design and construction of these
projects and so I thought of several
titles for what I would say as I heard
as I heard the conversations that
preceded me since I think about the
whole campus I thought of the title
putting cutting-edge architecture in its
place then I thought of something
slightly different which was creating a
composition one building at a time or a
few buildings per generation
what's one's responsibility for that
composition because we're in one today
then as I thought of how buildings
evolve and and how our campus evolved
and Chuck vests faith-based development
theory I thought about titles such as
this getting it right while making it up
as you go then as I listen to Frank and
and Bob I thought making sense and
taking action in the face of opposing
viewpoints then finally I thought
something like this how to preserve your
career while responding to your boss
his advisor and two architects that we
are working with as we speak so with
that in mind you can see whether the
next one page of notes that I offer you
actually live up to those titles or not
when you're in the management role in a
college or university or for that matter
and most any other organization and you
know you don't know everything and you
know no one really does but you have to
get something done
you rely on good processes and
serendipity and so I think one of the
most important things universities can
do in thinking about themselves because
they do create long lived things they do
create intellectual cities that persist
over long periods of time as our
viewpoint was influenced by Jim Ackerman
this morning and looking back to the
16th and 17th centuries for example so
these these processes involve everyone
from administrators to architectural
advisers to especially the faculty who
may live in the buildings to the
students who may live in the buildings
and so the process of organized
engagement the structuring of chaos the
management of organized Anarchy's which
universities are becomes a challenge and
a test of our abilities and if we have
good processes in which we can manage P
dialectics I think good things can
happen and I think over the last many
years at MIT but in particular during
those that I've experienced up close
many good things have happened so let's
think of the dialectics for a moment the
Commons versus the cloisters we saw very
different views of the world evolved
over the centuries that were presented
to us earlier today there are times when
surely the cloisters dominate over the
Commons as for example over many years
MIT consumed much of what was its common
space and turned them into cloisters of
laboratories and offices there are
periods where the Commons such as great
courts and great hallways take
precedence so there is a constant
dialectic between
the Commons and the cloisters I might
give you a couple of examples of two of
our recent buildings that engage the
Commons and the cloisters in different
ways
if you look at Simmons hall over half of
that buildings I would characterize as
the Commons there are great dining
facilities there is a multi-purpose room
that looks like an interior amphitheater
there are several common clusters of
computers there are breakout areas along
every floor where one can either seek
solitude and in small spaces or seek
friends over a microwave oven and a
refrigerator and I might add that that
building has re to MIT some of the
earlier ideas of the Commons within a
single building the residential colleges
of the European universities especially
the Oxford and Cambridge models saw
residence halls as residential colleges
in which one engaged in a common
activity around dining there was not a
lot of common activity around dining but
I might add that the way we've
approached it in Simmons and the
interest of the building and the
activities that go on in at other than
just students living in their rooms have
brought dining back to MIT we are
migrating from refueling to eating to
dining over a generation on the other
hand there are very different kinds of
Commons if you look at Stata you will
see them as small lounges that you find
when you walk out of your cloisters look
down a spiral staircase and see inviting
areas where people have their laptops on
or talking with each other or writing on
grease boards you will see the Commons
in particular for the kind of engagement
of random encounters in the great
student Street in that building a kind
of huge shunt line of the infinite
corridor leading students from one end
of the campus to the other on a diagonal
in this case in such a way that we hope
they will meet enjoy spend time come
together in common interest but perhaps
uncommon intellectual encounters there's
another dialogue that we have to
negotiate because money does matter and
in some cases unique buildings do cost
more then then in a sense knockoff
buildings or buildings that have been
built before it is also the case that
you have average buildings really good
buildings perhaps original buildings
there's a constant dialectic between the
good the original there's the dialectic
between sustainability and style I'm
picking up on some of the words of our
commentators this morning sustainability
is a hugely important issue at a
university if we imagine that we're here
forever then in some sense we might
manage man imagine that our buildings
are here forever
but how do we make them sustainable from
the standpoint of the quality of their
original struction structure to the
adaptability to new ideas new science
new technology new inhabitants over many
years there is a sense in which Frank I
think and Bob this morning agreed on the
issue of sustainability the notion of
the adaptability of a loft building the
adaptability of the main group as it was
conceived by Bosworth and the
adaptability of the interior spaces of
the Stata Center all fit that idea very
very clearly finally we are challenged
always in budget matters with what I
would call the cheap versus the durable
and I want to speak a little bit about
that in much of the commercial world
there is a sense that buildings have
relatively short lives those lives are
essentially the depreciation period that
the accountants put the building's on
and that's any place from 25 to 30 years
you would also note in most cases
developers even long-term developers
leave their projects within 25 to 30
years some much earlier than that there
is not the expectation of longevity in
these buildings as we would have here
and then I want to talk to you a little
bit about the concept of durable and
universities perhaps Bosworth's building
are our greatest examples they're the
original they
enormous ly durable even as some
predicted in the early days that they
would sink on their piles into the
Cambridge into the into the Charles
River basin they have not they'd still
live on wood piles and are in great
shape today enormous ly durable in their
in their presence to the world enormous
ly adaptable in their interior so I want
to give you a notion of about buildings
that at universities that somewhat
analogous to how we think of our
financial assets when I'm not thinking
about our physical assets I'm supposed
to think about our financial assets
because I function with our treasurer as
a financial officer of the Institute
when we ask someone for an endowment
they know what that means
they will give us the principal we will
invest it wisely in such a way that the
gift lives on in perpetuity we are to
use only the earnings on the gift to
support activities on the campus thus if
the gift is to endow a chair for a
faculty member we should be able to
demonstrate to the donor several hundred
years after she has left money with us
that the chair is still filled by an
active faculty member and supported in
the way she imagined many centuries ago
if you think of our physical assets that
way as an endowment where a patron to a
university a donor gives us a resource
and we act as a patron in the sense that
we then ask good designers good
architects to create with us something
which could live in perpetuity then I
think we have a sense of what we are
trying to do in universities I was
reminded of something about the sense of
longevity from another sector of the
world in a conversation that I was
having with buzz udell from Los Angeles
buzz is at the forum of firm of more
ruble and UDL has done some work with us
on the campus did a lot of work with me
on the west coast it both UCLA and
Caltech he was in conversation with
with Rafael Moneo who designed the new
Catholic cathedral on Bunker Hill in Los
Angeles whose client of course was the
Catholic Church and Cardinal Mahony he
reports the conversation that Cardinal
Mahony was having with the architect and
the engineers the Cardinal was very
concerned about whether the building
would last through earthquakes after all
the reason for its being constructed was
that the last earthquake in Los Angeles
of significant size that Northridge
Creek had permanently damaged Saint
Bibiana z-- the old old Cathedral in
downtown Los Angeles
it was beyond repair beyond rehab and
the church was to build a new cathedral
so when he asked what would be the best
way to construct a building of the
height and shape and size imagined the
report came back from any as anyone in
Los Angeles would know it's a reinforced
concrete is the strongest building in
that kind of environment
so then Cardinal Mahony asked well what
are the downsides of this kind of
construction and the architect of the
engineers observed that over many many
years
concrete sometimes leaks water gets
inside the rebar rusts the structural
integrity could begin to erode this can
happen 50 60 years down the road sort of
like no problem and Buzz udell reports
that the Cardinal looked very troubled
and very puzzled and he said I'm not
comfortable with that and the question
went back well how long do you expect
this building to last and his response
without blinking an eye was a minimum of
five hundred years so it is reported
that the rebar in that building is of
extremely high grade stainless steel
and that as buzz you Dell said when the
big one hits Los Angeles the Cathedral
may not be in the same place but it will
be in one piece and so perhaps we should
take a lead from Cardinal Mahony about
how we think of the longevity of our
buildings and how we act as not only
solicitors of the patronage of great
donors who helped us but act on their
behalf and on behalf of future
generations to work with great
architects and designers to create
something that has a life well beyond
our generation so those are my thoughts
based on the conversation we've had
today and I thank you for the
opportunity to speak well this always
happens to me that I can't keep people
in control and these panels so we're
pretty much running out of time so what
on that note of back to faith-based
development in a different sense with me
let me thank everybody who's
participated in the in the program today
I think we've had an absolutely terrific
set of set of presentations that's given
some insight into the way this campus is
evolving and the way it will evolve in
in the future and and me conclude by
saying
onward and upward we still have a couple
more buildings to do in this process and
we're determined to do them so that's
the next thing we'll do
but let me call on Jane father to close
the proceedings thank you I apologize
that we didn't have time for questions
and thank you again to Jean Wasserman
and come back next year when will last
time we did rock and roll then sex and
we did instead of drugs we did
architecture which is sort of the same
thing but anyway come next year thank
you